black ops cold war multiplayer has been
revealed
xbox series x finally has a confirmed
release date and price
and watchdog legion's got a release date
too i'm persia and this is your save
state for wednesday september 9th
the cold war multiplayer reveal was this
morning and we even got a chance to play
a bit
there are some new modes new maps and
more with a beta release
coming next month some of the new modes
include combined arms which is a 12 on
12
domination style mode vip escort which
is a
six on six slower pace mode where you
have to escort a specified teammate to
each location without dying
and fire team where 40 players split up
into groups
to complete designated objectives armada
is a brand new map that is a group of
ships out at sea
with your main ways to travel between
boats being things like zip lines
jet skis or good old swimming
multiplayer beta weekends are coming up
in
october based on which platform you're
using so if you want all the details on
your specified weekend
or want to see a closer look at the guns
and other cold war gameplay
then check out our coverage on
gamespot.com
after months of waiting speculating and
leaks
we finally have the price and release
date of the xbox series
x yesterday the less powerful xbox
series
s was announced at 299 bucks
and today microsoft confirmed that the
xbox series x
is going to be 499. we also now know
that we'll be able to purchase either
version
on november 10th with pre-order starting
on september 22nd
less than two weeks away both consoles
are going to be a part of the xbox
all access program which lets you pay
off the consoles over time and will also
include
other services like game pass ultimate
xbox live gold
x cloud streaming and an ea play
subscription
so now that the dates and prices are set
in stone
which version are you getting the series
x or the series s
that's not the only release date we got
today ubisoft has announced that
watchdog legions will launch on
playstation 4
xbox one stadia and pc on october 29th
and of course on the xbox series x or s
on november 10th when the console
launches
getting either the ps4 or the xbox one
versions gets you a free update to the
next gen versions when they're out
even though we still don't know when
that'll be for the ps5
assassin's creed valhalla will follow
suit as it was moved up a week to also
launch
on november 10th and speaking of ubisoft
games there is going to be another
ubisoft forward tomorrow at 12 p.m
pacific
where we're probably gonna see more
watchdog legions and valhalla
but we might also see some other things
when that time comes you already know
we're gonna be covering all the action
right here on gamespot that is a wrap
for your
wednesday but thank you for tuning in
feel free to give me a follow on twitter
at persia underscore exo
and we'll catch you next time see ya
[Music]
you